on
va être exigeante on ne sera pas
directement
impliqué dans un premier temps dans les
combats mais nous suivons nous sommes
pleinement concerné par ce qui se passe
en ukraine
nous devrons suivre pas à pas ce qui se
passe pour être en mesure de protéger et
d'assurer la sécurité de l'europe dans
cette région actuellement menacées
[Musique]
à
non
[Musique]
twist défensive lines vie d'une autre
site chronofoot reed richards ross
timide et les stop the world paul out of
summer rain and game in good faith in
diplomatique et france 2 west ans du
président nicollin for peace
vous
comment la mission c'est en vain
roumanie on va dans une base de l'otan
et donc donc ya pas de raison on n'a pas
pour mission de mettre un pied en
ukraine pour l'instant on va passer sur
le front du tout et donc on fera notre
mission de présence